افتتح المستشار الالماني اولف شولت المحطه
العائمه الثانيه لاستقبال الغاز الطبيعي
في بناء لبنى شماليه المانيا
وستزود المحطه الولايات الشرقيه الالمانيه
بنحو خمسه مليارات متر مكعب من الغاز
الطبيعي سنويا وقال مسؤول المحلي للجزيره
ان اولى الشحنات المتوقع وصولها ستنطلق من
مصر وترسوا المحطه العائمه بميناء الصناعي
وهي عباره عن سفينه تحول الغاز السائل الى
حالته الغازيه ومرتبطه بشبكه انابيب الغاز
الفيدراليه الالمانيه
من بلده من شمالي المانيا حيث مقر المحطه
العائمه للغاز الطبيعي الينا عيسى الطيبي
عيسى اطلعنا على اهميه هذه المحطه
والاستراتيجيه التي تتبعها المانيا
لمواجهه النقص الحاد في الغاز
نعم جلال هذه المحطه هي المحطه الثانيه من
المحطات الخمسه التي اعلنتها المانيا او
بما تسمى استراتيجيه الغاز العائم وهذه
الاستراتيجيه لمواجهه الناقصه في
الامدادات من الغاز جلال هذه المحطات تقول
الحكومه الالمانيه بامكانها ان تزود
المانيا
نتيجه احتجاجاتها من الغاز الى ربما من
الجيد نذكر استراتيجيه هذا المكان جلال
وهي اولا بان المحطه العائمه هي عباره عن
سفينه راسيه كما ترونها هناك هذه السفينه
تقوم باستقبال السفن اصغر تاتي من هذا
الممر المائي من بحر البلطيق وتقوم
بتزويدها بشكل يومي برحلات المكوكيه وتقوم
هذه السفينه المرتبطه بشبكه الانابيب
الفيدراليه الالمانيه للغاز تقوم بتحويل
الغاز السائل الى حالته الغازيه ومن ثم
دفعه الى انابيب ال ال الدوله الالمانيه
المفارقه ايضا في هذا المكان جلال لذا
رايت منه وراي ذلك المبنى الطويل وهو محطه
نوويه كانت ابنتها المانيا الشرقيه وبناه
السوفياء تحديدا وتم اغلاقها في اليوم
الاول من اعلان الوحده بين شاطرين المانيا
الشرقيه والغربيه وهذا الممر المائي هو
كان احد همم وهو كان مصمم فقط لتبريد همم
المفاعل النووي ذلك الذين ترونه بدائي
يقول اهل المنطقه هنا بانه يشبه بانه صوره
طبق الاصل لما فاعل خير من مفارقات هذا
المكان الاستراتيجي من لبنان هو ايضا انه
تقع به محطه النور 2 كما اا نضربهم ترونها
في الكاميرا الان محطه نورد ستريم الاثنين
المحطه الضخم والضغط هذه هي المحطه التي
اوقفتها المانيا بعد حرب روسيا حرب الروسي
على اوكرانيا وبالتالي هذا المكان يظلم
ثلاث اجنحه مهمه للطاقه نورلد ستريم همم
والمحطه النوويه السابقه السوفياتيه او
التي بنت المانيا الشرقيه
والان هي الميناء العائم او محطه الغاز
الطبيعي
لذلك هذه هذا هذا الاعلان الذي عندما قال
المستشار اليوم في في حفل الافتتاح بان
المانيا قررت
وادرك قبل حرب اوكرانيا بان ما سيحدث هو
ان تقوم روسيا
بوضعيه يدها على ملف الطاقه وقال باننا
ساعدنا باكرا لهذا اليوم وقمنا باجراء
الاحتياجات الموازنه لالمانيا وقلنا قمنا
بدفع كل الامكانات الماديه والبشريه
لاعاده بنا هذه المحطات والتي سماها بانها
منقذ مهم ومنفذ مهم للطاقه في المانيا
وبالتالي استضاعت المانيا كما قال بان
تتجاوزه هذا الشتاء بثلاثه وبانها قادره
على تجاوز الشتاء القادم وبان خلال 200
يوما فقط استطاعت المانيا ان تدشن المحطه
الثانيه وهو رقم كما يقول المستشار بانه
رقم تجلى في التزام الالمان المهندسين الى
المانيا العامل الماهر الالمانيه في
التزام مع موقف الحكومه وبالتالي استطاعت
ان تخرج من هذه القبض قبضه الغازي الروسي
نعم شكرا لك يا عيسى من مقر المحطه
العائمه للغاز الطبيعي في لبنان